when nadeshda artomanova strolls through
her hometown of seleme with her
boyfriend they still run across relics
of the soviet era
factory ruins emblazoned with the
russian word for peace
but in these factories the activities
carried out in secret for decades were
anything but peaceful
[Applause]
my parents grew up in russia and were
sent to work not far from here
that was because the small town on the
baltic was a center of soviet nuclear
production
officially it did not even exist
it wasn't even marked on soviet-era maps
today it belongs to estonia and the
european union
but most of its residents were born in
russia
mainly elderly people
mikhail kafonov still takes pride in the
secret mining of uranium oxide in the
region
this chapter from his past can be seen
at the local history museum
was employed at a uranium enrichment
plan
if we hadn't started here under those
tough conditions we never would have had
any uranium or the atom bomb
and what would that have meant for the
fate of the soviet union
america already had the atom bomb
opinions like that make nadezhda cringe
the image of a forbidden town still
looms over sileme and that is why most
of its young people are leaving
the 30 year old has also thought about
moving to estonia's capital talon
i
but we
uranium is no longer mined here but the
vast heaps of oil shale used as an
energy source litter the region
but now celeme's future could look like
this
nadezhda is studying computer
programming at a newly founded
information technology school
a number of estonian startup
millionaires made it possible
it's one way for the town to shake off
its dark past
there there will be a lot of change
happening around here because we are
moving away from the oil shade mining
so there's a need for new kind of
innovation new industries to come into
idahoma so why not i.t
the estonian government also wants to
abandon the old industries and invest in
the new the promenade leading to the sea
has been thoroughly revamped but
discontent among the ethnic russians
living here runs high the past is still
cast in a dim light
things used to be better here than in
the towns in russia
supplies of goods were better
they were better closed than anywhere
else and of course the people had jobs
the russian border lies just over 20
kilometers away but few of nadezhda's
generation feel drawn to the land of
their ancestors
i've been to russia a few times but i
couldn't imagine living there
the mentality here in estonia is
different
and so
i've never even thought about it
[Music]
veteran mikhail kafanov can't understand
that
recently he received a medal from moscow
for his work in uranium production
he admits the town was closed off to
outsiders at the time but he never had a
problem with that
if anyone asked we said we worked in oil
shale processing
it was prohibited to talk about our real
work
nobody ever held that against us later
on
but nadezhda is looking ahead
once she'd begun studying to be a
programmer she gave up her plans to move
elsewhere
i'd like to travel a little and get to
know other cities
maybe even go abroad
but now i know i'll definitely be coming
back
i want to use the experiences i gather
elsewhere for my own town
thanks to young residents like nadezhda
artamanova the once closed town of
seleme could leave its dark past behind
it once and for all